What are things to look for when you're
debating whether to raise your voice or
yell do to those under you
being lazy or unmotivated.
Y'All talk a lot about the importance
of self control and not just losing it,
but would you say there's a time and place
for raising the intensity while still
being respectful towards your guys? So
there you go. Yelling and screaming,
get some. Sometimes you gotta
just drop the Hammer. Jocko,
uh, yelled and screamed at us
all the time. Like, I've, I've,
I've talked about it on this, you know,
I think on the podcast we started talking
about all the time and the number of
times that Jocko screamed
and yelled at me zero,
zero times in all the years
that we worked together.
And I know I gave him a least dozens,
maybe hundreds of opportunities
to want to travel.
He done that and he didn't do that because
he realized that it wasn't effective.
So, uh, now listen, there, there is,
uh, there is a time where, you know,
if there's a,
a major safety issue going on and you're
trying to get people's attention and
you want people to cease fire, uh, our,
you need to rally the troops where you
got to raise your voice and get people's
attention. Uh, and I think that's, you
can't be afraid to do that as a leader.
Certainly Times where I'd
say, Hey, life pictures,
get those Bobby's lined up for
there or stuff like that. I mean,
for sure that's, is that
yelling? Well, yeah,
I'm definitely raising my voice and
using a loud voice, but I'm not doing it.
Whatever with anger, it's just,
hey, you got to hear me. And so,
and also, you know, there is
times where you've got to,
you've got to pick up the intensity in
your voice so that people realize there's
something important happening, right?
There's just enough now you don't want
to yell and scream and get all crazy.
But to be like, Hey, I need vehicles here
now. Like that is different than, hey,
can you get the vehicles over here? Now,
those are two different things and you
I would react differently if I heard
those two voices. So yes,
now to go [inaudible] now,
no one that we're creating
a whole panic situation.
But that's a great point too, right?
And it's, it's kind of, you know,
never cry wolf story.
So when, when you're,
if you're yelling all the time,
how do you do these vehicles over here
right now when there's nothing at stake
and it's no big deal and it's
just a routine movement, you know,
then when you do that and you really
need it, then no one's paying attention.
They think, oh, that's just Lafe
yelling again into the radio.
So I think that's another reason why I
actually have seen Jocko raise his voice
on one occasion. And when there was a,
a serious issue that needed to be
addressed and you needed to get a person's
attention to show just how
serious of a situation it was.
And it got everybody's attention. It
got everybody's attention right away,
cause you never did that. And when you
did do it, it was like, oh man. Yeah, I,
and I was always tell that to
leaders, like being on the radio,
and this goes for being in a meeting,
right? If you go to a meeting,
if you're in charge of a meeting
and you talk the whole time,
and then you have something important
to say at the end, well that's great,
but it's not as impactful as when you
say very few things during the meeting.
And then at the end you
say, hey guys, listen up.
Here's what's going on with this. And
everyone, everyone pays attention.
So I've said this before, the less
you talk, the more people listen.
And that goes true here. The more
you yell, the less people listen.
And it takes away the opportunity.
If you ever do have to yell,
it's going to have zero impact.
So my blanket statement is used to hardly
ever have to raise your voice and you
should just barely ever happen.